[MUSIC PLAYING]
WESAM AL MEDHOUN: Hello, my
name is Wesam Al Medhoun,
I am a visiting scholar in the
MIT-UTM Malaysia Sustainable
Cities Program, and assistant
professor at the Islamic
University of Gaza, Palestine.
In this video,
I'll be describing
ways in which Penang,
a city in Malaysia,
is trying to reduce
vehicle emissions.
Traffic related
air pollution has
an adverse impact on the
environment and human health.
Exposure to traffic emissions
create health problems
such as higher rates of
asthma, cardiovascular disease,
and bad development in children,
pre-term and low birth weight
infants, childhood leukemia,
and premature death.
Traffic emissions also
contain a large amount
of carbon dioxide, a
primary greenhouse gas that
contributes to global warming.
SPEAKER1: People are burning
huge amounts of coal, oil,
and natural gas to
generate electricity.
This releases harmful
greenhouse gases which
trap heat in the atmosphere.
SPEAKER 2: No wonder I have
been feeling really warm
SPEAKER 1: As more
fossil fuels are burned,
the greenhouse gases will
trap more heat, causing
your temperature to rise.
WESAM AL MEDHOUN: Cities
can reduce vehicle emissions
by reducing private
vehicle ownership,
by increasing the cost of owning
a vehicle, such as increasing
cost of a registration,
increasing cost of parking,
etc, regularly enforcing
emission standards, inspection
of all vehicles to
eliminate bad cars,
improving the efficiency
of road networks,
and providing safe efficient
and affordable public transport,
and integrating land use
and transportation planning.
But not all of these strategies
are visible in every context.
I will therefore, focus on
the case of Penang, a state
within Malaysia, to illustrate
how the context affects
these strategies.
Why Malaysia?
The better growth of
the Malaysian economy
in recent decades has
resulted in the deterioration
of the environment.
Malaysia is ranked as
the fourth most polluted
of 14 Asian countries.
In particular, air pollution
and degradation of air quality
is a problem.
World Health
Organization reports
show that approximately
1900 Malaysians
died due to outdoor
air pollution in 2012.
According to the Malaysian
Ministry of Health,
diseases respiratory system
are the second greatest reason
for hospitalization and death.
Respiratory diseases are
responsible for approximately
one out of ten hospitalizations,
and one out of five deaths.
Vehicle emissions are the single
largest cause of air pollution
in Malaysia, accounting for
82% of total air pollutants.
Haze from forest
fires further degrades
air quality in Malaysia.
Penang is an example of a
rapidly developing state
in Malaysia, with a
problem of air degradation.
Private vehicle
ownership in Penang
is higher than the
national average,
but they are trying to
do something about it.
Penang has the third largest
economy of Malaysian states,
and has a population
of 1.6 million.
It is on the Northwest coast
of peninsular Malaysia,
by the Straits of Malacca.
It is composed of two
parts-- Penang Island, where
the seats of the
government is, and Seberang
Perai, the mainland part.
Penang has a higher number
of registered motor vehicles
per person than other
Malaysian states.
There are 2.52 million
registered motor vehicles,
an average of 1.25
cars per person.
PROFESSOR FARHAN:
Penang, in the island,
as well as in the mainland,
have delayed the main spine
for the public transport.
So because of that,
more and more people
go towards private forms of
transport, either motorcycle
or cars, and that, of course,
adds to the congestion problem.
And when there's
congestion, and there's
high volume of cars
with low speed,
we know that it
affects the pollution.
WESAM AL MEDHOUN: Like many
places around the world,
Penang is trying to improve
air quality by taking measures
to reduce vehicle emissions.
What has been
Penang done so far?
Directed traffic law in one or
two lanes, based on intensity
to reduce congestion
on busy streets.
Improved traffic
management control
through adjusting the
timing of traffic signals.
And by constructing roundabouts
to reduce congestion.
Providing free shuttle
buses from the mainland
to the island.
These buses are meant to
transport of civil servant who
are working at the island
government compound,
and executives who are
working at the Bayan Lepas
industrial area created a
dedicated bike lane for parts
of Georgetown, the main city
of Penang Island, increased
enforcement of
emission standards
inspection during
car registration,
and changing of car ownership,
and introduced car-free day
at certain parts of Georgetown.
These strategies have
reduced emission levels,
and consequently improve the
air quality in the state.
The state also plans to reduce
private vehicle ownership
by providing affordable
and efficient
public transportation.
MR. MUSTAQIN: But the
very poor connectivity
in terms of public transport
because the public transport
there is now-- many old buses.
Now we're heading
[INAUDIBLE] and also
[INAUDIBLE] traffic problem that
will impact our air pollution.
WESAM AL MEDHOUN: In
2015, the state of Penang
hired an independent
consultant to develop
a public transportation
master plan,
but they face major
challenges which
are-- transportation decisions
are made at the federal level.
Even a change in
the bus line running
through the town
of Georgetown needs
to be approved by the
federal government.
This makes it very challenging
for the state government
to make changes.
Limited budget for
transportation planning,
because revenues powers lies
within the federal government,
the state government has
a very limited budget
for making improvements to
its transportation network.
PROFESSOR FARHAN:
So this all adds out
to non- sustainable practices.
And I think the
state government this
trying very hard to solve this.
And they have come up
with several strategies
and they introduced a
transport master plan.
Part of that
transport master plan
is an extensive rail network.
Unfortunately they are not
able to secure any funding
from the federal government
so they have to be creative,
and perhaps this is
another challenge
for sustainability, financing.
And I think Penang is
trying an initiative that
is self-sustaining
through public partnership
with the public- private
partnership model.
WESAM AL MEDHOUN:
Penang authorities
plan to finance the
transport master
plan by selling reclaimed land.
But they have yet to do
an environmental impact
assessment.
Therefore, while
public transportation
is critical to reducing
vehicle emissions,
reducing negative
environmental impacts
requires thoughtful finance
and implementation mechanisms.
To conclude, Penang
decision makers
might adopt sustainable
transportation policies
that have been implemented
by five major Asian cities
like Hong Kong, Tokyo,
Singapore, Seoul, and Shanghai.
These include promoting
public transportation,
integrating land use
and transport planning,
and instituting travel
demand management
to bring about sustainable
transportation system.
Adding to that, more stringent
car emissions inspection,
and expanding the
free-car day can further
reduce traffic emissions.
Transport planning and
implementation in Penang
still faces several
challenges that
need to be handled wisely in
order to be more sustainable.
At the same time,
positive element
of Penang's
implemented strategies
are a promising example
for less developed cities.
[MUSIC PLAYING]